oh wow there are actually people here
I'll let our people here welcome welcome
to scum and villainy for a black man
beyond I'm mark Barnard
I'm Phil Lamarr yeah I mean it was very
fitting that a hive of scum and villainy
would have the police okay and I should
do this now because I promised I would
do it Oh drinks are on me
here's the [ __ ] credit girl I'm
buying all the drinks tonight whoo [ __ ]
it Pam money money money well birthday
to me happy birthday to you and since it
is your birthday I got you a present
[Laughter]
we're gonna have to sing for you oh you
don't get [ __ ] but mark you get a VIN
because this was the only recognizably
black character at time I well I mean
they had a war machine and a black
panther but that could be anybody under
there that's awesome I got a thing and
happy drinking to all of you yes and I
what's your name Carina
okay well it's doubles she gets doubles
but we also have to sing right okay
everybody ready one two three
[Music]
happy birthday to you happy birthday all
[Applause]
right all right um well yeah yeah
see also I was listening to the other
episodes and I realized you bring on a
lot of guest hosts that sound just like
you I'm listening to you and Todd
stashwick wait which one is that talking
the tall one so I mean Katie I could
tell ya no show I decide thankfully like
she made a thing over there and we want
to make sure that we don't have that
problem for people listen to this so for
the rest of the episode I'm gonna talk
like this excellent so you know when
it's me talking and when it's Marc we're
always doing have you been I've been
good I the last time I saw you I want to
say [ __ ] it's a Comic Con probably so
San Diego yeah I think so yeah well if
at any given point in time I'm probably
at a comic Oh indeed but the last time
we did this you had been a guest before
right hosted a thing we were shooting
out of like a supply closet we didn't
have a live bar audience and it was
talking about [ __ ] yeah and so I'm very
glad we got to bring you back into the
into the into the mothership I know in
this nice big thing with people looking
at me I know super weird right do this
all day I'll just have to remember not
to whisper wait they can see me good I'm
good yeah I got you know it's a black
nerd night so it decided to you know
like on my leather
you got your leathers you got your study
black and then
my nerve excellent rock on gotta
represent we all represent we were we
were talking in the in the green room
which is the green the green alley yeah
the green room you you if you've been
here enough you know exactly what that
is and I was a I was always exhorting
how much that I'm a big fan of Watchmen
mm-hmm and I think that episode six and
seven six is maybe one of the best
episodes of TV I've ever seen seven
while not quite as good as six dropped a
bunch of [ __ ] bombs that were kind of
amazing so I'm fully on board I'm kind
of in love with that [ __ ] cool I've
rarely run into the person who's like
I'm just not feeling it that's me so
split okay
well because I'll tell you why I was
explaining it to my daughter today cuz
and my daughter is a soccer player
doesn't give a [ __ ] about any of this
nerd [ __ ] so I'm like am NOT love and
watch me she's like whatever like no
look the comic book was taking the
classic superhero tropes and laying them
into real-world type situations like if
this if the real word if there were
superheroes in the real world they would
all be crazy [ __ ] that's Alan
Moore's premise you know but to me this
one is taking the real world and like
sprinkling in some [ __ ] from comic books
and I'm like I don't why I don't get and
it really it's I find it scary and
depressing then then you familiar with
Damon Lindelof work I'm not because have
you seen the leftovers depressing his
[ __ ] hey like it's it's veins slitting
television at its finest yeah but I'm
not expecting to Rima Kissin to show up
on the [ __ ] leftovers I keep waiting
for that cameo in Watchmen no I I
understand that critique
I don't vibe with it
I understand it I don't know why it's
Watchmen the same same problem I had
with Joker like
you just make it a movie about a crazy
[ __ ] why you gotta tie it to my
[ __ ] childhood because nostalgia
nostalgia mining mist aljahmeir
dig deep in that vein yeah I mean I did
it it seemed abundantly clear that Damon
was not interested at all in remaking
The Watchmen right all right we're just
smart which yes you're not gonna be
better than the book yeah and don't do a
shot-for-shot Gus Van Sant remake of it
nobody needs that we already had one of
those so it was how do I progress this
story what is the next Watchmen story
what is the thing that of Alan Moore was
writing this story today that he would
be preoccupied with Alan Moore would not
be preoccupied with black people I can
tell you that right now
yeah he might he might throw in a more
yes some some dark eldritch guy exactly
but I do have to say the Jean smart
episode bumped me up it was like okay
this is about performance I mean and I'm
looking at all these amazing actors like
okay there must be some good [ __ ] they
must have read something real good
they're making is like Jeremy Irons like
yeah Jeremy you're just gonna be
shooting by yourself like I'll do that
he's doing all of the acting right like
Jeremy Irons is what do you need what do
you need me to do I'll do everything rub
my thighs right and alone in a room
where everyone else is doing nothing
right we're all being clones spoiler
absolutely sure Jeremy I guess hopefully
burst into song no no I I what I want
now is I want like Jeremy Irons as
Adrian Veidt and Carl Weathers as the
lead bounty hunter for Mandalorian begin
the scene together what they do is shout
[ __ ] no I've got all this money here let
me buy you a drink man
very very health hail-fellow-well-met
everybody's name from across the room
well as we saw the whole bar is [ __ ]
bounty hunters come sit in my booth with
me like we're like this far you did a
great job man no it's a bounty hunter
bar you can you can tell cuz there's
like a little slats under the table so
people can't shoot each other
yeah just like bulletproof groin area
exactly who shot first
nobody you can't shoot first in a bounty
hunter bar we learned our lesson from
free movies yet that those grito guys
keep showing is there a name for that
race thank you this mask okay so what is
your as race so so baby
not even in some sort of like deep cut
like 1991
novelization somewhere nice right cuz
they're just like Hermits actually the
only person who knows is Frank Oz he has
it on he has it as a [ __ ] stamp and
ain't nobody gonna look at that ha ha ha
and we've learned something new about
mark after a night of buying drinks at
scum and villainy maybe you want to go
all the way to Oz alright so not lovin
Watchmen and you were not loving
mandalorian I was not loving Manilow I
had to pull my car over listening to you
and Katie talk yeah no but like I said
like I figured out I reek a lab rat
myself to Mandalorian because it's a
kids show and not for nothing wrong with
that what do you think it's a kids show
oh it's totally a kid show it is not a
kid show okay it's a Western
no yes no yes it's it's a samurai
Western right which kids love
well there are samurai westerns on the
[ __ ] Nick Nick jr. all night not I'm
sorry what's the title of this Samurai
Jack ah oh really you have not seen fit
season if you think that [ __ ] is for
kids hey looks like a penis spoiler miss
Dixon said well then [ __ ] you it's three
years old if you go complain about a
spoiler more than two weeks later don't
care your job was to watch it right
didn't do your job
no okay so let's let's go through very
quickly the plot of the third episode of
Mandalorian okay mando comes into the
bar gets paid like what do I do
I handed in Yoda they took him get paid
what happens I regret it I'm gonna go
get that Yoda back goes gets the Yoda
back right once you guys shoot them out
and then they move on you go over the
Yoda
mando you're gonna pay for it there's
little like four beats in this story it
is super [ __ ] simple there's no
reversals there's no surprises it is
ABCD it is easy enough for your average
eight-year-old to follow the emotional
complexity is there it's he's got regret
there's [ __ ] Yoda he's super cute he
feels betrayed like you'd like that's
all well and good right but it is not
advanced story it is not challenging
story it is a child's story as Star Wars
has always been you ain't talked to a
lot of children lately have you no I'm
confused by Mandalorian no and none of
them would my kids don't watch it
but it's not because of this simplicity
I mean simplicity is not necessarily I
mean I'm not saying it's a bad thing I'm
not saying that it's not but that's why
you're saying it's it's a kid show I'm
saying because of the simplicity because
a 38 minutes long what the [ __ ] is that
I'm a grown-up
I can sit down for an hour so it's it's
shorter because children's attention
spans are shorter there is nothing
there's nothing surprising there's
nothing complicated it's incredibly easy
to fall see you're wrong it's not for
children it's for old people it's for
old people it's a Western it is for
people in their 70s who remember [ __ ]
Chuck Connors with a shotgun so in other
words children no because children want
[ __ ] that they want cursing and rapping
and you can't get a kid to watch good
versus evil they want you know but if
you catch me they want Beyonce if you
catch them young enough if you catch
them like get like six and seven like yo
watch [ __ ] anything III had those
children who watched [ __ ] Teletubbies
and Barney and that kind of [ __ ] no
no see cuz I had to keep my kids from
watching Disney shows cuz they were all
[ __ ] episodes of Three's Company with
the sex taken out you know but no it's
just it's all like Angry bad behavior
you know to me kids kids entertainment
these days is about transgression
so I mean because that's what kids what
kids want something that their parents
don't like so to you to call this a kid
show because it is you know solid and
simple I think it's simply just retro
yeah no I I hear what you're saying I
think they can be both things at once I
think you could have something no I
think you just don't like it no because
it's not challenging enough for you
no I just which is totally legit it's I
mean and and the last time I talked
about it it was I I kind of was hoping
that Star Wars was going to grow with me
as I got older and after a fashion it
kind of did a little
you know Empire is absolutely a darker
movie I mean whatever and then you get
into like taxation routes that's all
right and then rogue one is a for-real
[ __ ] war movie like there is no
mistaking that as a kids fable the way
in New Hope is a new hope it's
absolutely here's his young farm boy he
goes to save a princess from an evil bad
guy in a castle that's made of shiny
things in space and by the time you get
to rogue one it's the like the futility
of war the the devastation of losing all
your friends these sort of the abyss of
emotional just just just rat Brian all
right cool it's about [ __ ] criminals
on the edge and it's that you know the
Empire has fallen there's no government
it's just lawlessness and we can plan
these like kind of moral gray zones and
who's good and who's bad and like that's
not at all what the show is and it just
took me a second to be like oh I thought
we're dealing with bounty hunters we're
dealing with Boba Fett's like second
cousin twice removed
we're gonna be in like a darker place
cute he's pressing the buttons any
screwing things off [ __ ] so you had a
different at you see okay because I came
into it expecting a Western and westerns
aren't dark yeah but they got dark
mm-hmm like you know once you get to
like Wild Bunch once you get to like you
know even [ __ ] 3:10 to Yuma ain't no
[ __ ] to spring picnic even High Noon
is like kind of morally complex right
once you got past they like 40s and 50s
and people began to reexamine the
Western has a form right bring new
things to it it got darker but not
knowing what I was gonna get right those
first trailers what oh [ __ ] Ivan Sergio
Leone land I'm in a bunch of bad dudes
doing bad things no no no good guy well
it's it's actually gray guy deciding to
be good guy right you know which cool
now but I just once I know what it is
now that I know what it is and I'm
absolving myself prospect ations for it
right I'm greeting it on its own level
and now I'm having a good time it was
just that that
it's why isn't this yeah why isn't this
what I thought you were selling it as
interesting this is now just what it is
and now I'm on board I get it and I'm
appreciating from a purely technical
perspective no [ __ ] like the things that
are doing are astonishing well and also
how long have you watched now and never
seen the lead characters face that I
think was probably the hardest thing
they had to sell this because as we saw
from spider-man 3 executives hate not
seeing the stars face James Franco open
your mask every time you have a line
even though you're in the middle of
battle yeah like there's a lot of Iron
Man 3 where's just [ __ ] Tony Stark
solving crimes like he's not in his
armor even though Favreau solved them
the the mask problem by like let's go
inside let's invent you know Jarvis and
just like hey half the movie is shot you
know just whatever in your face
flashlights on his face and it'll like
readouts from the inside exactly yeah
that'll be season two of the Mandalorian
regice will be inside the masts look at
all these [ __ ] bounty hunters in here
I'm so mad at them I'll never take this
mask off but I don't need to because I'm
inside so yeah I'm warming to the
mandalorian faster and faster
I had an odd experience this week in
that I wrote her a show called
Treadstone what's gone the USA
Treadstone okay
from the Jason Bourne universe though we
could never mention the word Jason
and/or born while writing a show so uh
so I wrote episode 7 of the first season
which aired this past Tuesday and it's a
it's a it's a weird experience watching
an episode of TV that you wrote that you
had no relation to for the past year
like I remember because television the
way in a perfect world the way it works
is you're in the writers room for about
a year right you write an episode you
produce that ups and you go to set and
you sit there for the production the
episode you see the actors do the thing
they got to make changes whatever
and your job is to be fly to Baton Rouge
Baton Rouge or Vancouver and and you sit
there for two weeks and you you offer
advice and you offer counsel and you
work for guidance and what does this
word mean Marc yeah wow that's that's
Plus that means you add things to things
yes but you're so pretty and then you
know you're done on production and the
show comes back and you're in the Edit
Bay and you get to watch them host the
episode and which is a whole third
version of writing it because basically
it's a law it's an elephant Jett
gestation process totally and like the
editorial process is another rewrite
like you're inventing narrative you're
shaving lines here you're adding lines
there you can do magic in an edit Bay oh
yeah
and so I've had that experience a couple
of times I've had it on alphas the very
first show that I was on I had it on
Castle Rock which was a ton of fun but
for this one like I I wrapped my the
writers room and that was it
right so it was December 2008 I went on
to another show after went out to carnal
verow after that and then production
happened like they were shooting it in
Budapest
oh so you surrogate at this one yeah so
just like okay their dog shooting it and
I know they're there because I'm seeing
Twitter photos of it you're not on the
show that was not on this set anymore my
time had wrapped I was I was game over
and so I knew that they're mercenary
like I'm mercy come in you do your job
but then you leave mark oh I got your
money
no I called weathers is now this weird
like super Mario's character I wish that
was my agent I wish my agent met me in a
bar with just money trapped in exactly
like I got your levee or just pay me in
metal nice so yeah so watching the
episode was like it was as if you had
dated a person [ __ ] ton of plastic
surgery but blind of sounds like she
used
the face is a little different not bad
just different and she's like two inches
taller limps funny like it was it was a
really dissociative experience of like I
kind of recognize it but not entirely
and like it's kind of doing the things
that were in the script that I wrote but
differently and not necessarily better
just different word of advice mark yeah
never be a sperm donor cuz cuz if this
seemed to be [ __ ] with you that's
gonna say Uncle Phil you can you give me
90s flashbacks I did an episode of The
Fresh Prince and I'm really to this day
believe Will Smith did not like me what
could you have done I didn't do anything
didn't you I didn't really I think I
just wasn't black enough see back then
black nerd was not a thing you were nerd
or black he wanted you more black less
Knar come on guys that's how you do it
Uncle Phil yeah so so my sort of
Treadstone like listen it's it's in
color and everything did you create any
characters
[Music]
there could be a character check no I
didn't know I didn't like listen doing
the show was super fun
the the and watching it was once it
became not mine and became the shows
like car chases badass and that they
doing some real kung-fu and that's
pretty cool I don't recognize it that's
ok maybe just like this is what m.nature
feels like well at least you didn't
create it
Frank Darabont we see the deadline
readers over there yeah yeah no that's
that's real yeah so that that went on
the air and I think people seem to like
the show which is cool and people seem
to you watching the show which is great
but when you like it better if they
didn't like it you [ __ ] with her now
nobody like her see if you've done what
I wanted to do upgraded Wow he's cute I
was hoping that this would be bad for
you you'd be in a convent or something
you know bitter means please in German
it's one of the five holy tastes you
can't have sweet without bitter no it's
super cool it's super cool all right so
we're talking about watch man we talked
about Mandalorian we talked about
redstone redstone and you judging from
what I see on your Instagram you you
have you have just learned how to use my
phone yes which is finally good job
actually I have my daughter doing it for
thank you kids for me that's why I had
kids their thumbs are smaller yeah
now sound like Liam Neeson there were
essential workers don't do it don't
don't say don't say Liam Neeson on a
black man beyond don't summon and
[ __ ] Malcolm did it before I'm going
over my shoulder but no you just thought
you just wrapped up on Supergirl
yeah yes yes how was how was that
experience it was great mmm ultimately
but it was also started out kind of
weird because I was originally hired for
a voice-over gig seriously yeah I mean
I'd done a gig on flash where I voiced a
live-action character they had the
villain rag doll apparently flash has a
lot of villains who have complete face
masks so a lot of us voice people are
getting tons of work like I don't have
the flat okay okay and yeah so I voice
ragdoll troy the contortionist was there
on set and then i came in and did all
the lines in post and then they called
me at the end of season four on
Supergirl we got you know John Jones
evil Martian brother and we want you to
voice because the character is CG like
whenever David Harewood is you know
write the Martian that's computerized
and so I did like that episode the end
of season 4 and then like four or five
episodes at the beginning of season five
where he would you know be in his
Martian form I would do those few lines
and then he would you know transform
into like a Girl Scout or Sean Astin in
a Girl Scout uniform in my dreams and so
you know I just late and then they said
actually you know what we're thinking
we're gonna put him in a human form
would you want to play it like now
granted I did hope and think that I
would be like in full on Martian regalia
you know like you know
the the booking of the de bandoliers
tape that the Zardoz castoffs right but
nope spent the entire run in sweats
I'm like really well then I'll get a
suit like space sweats
no no Astro sweat Lena Luthor apparently
does not design her prisoner we're just
like off the rack I'm sorry but I'm like
whatever I'm comfortable I can be what I
want
[Laughter]
melissa's gotta do a whole [ __ ] thing
that's right yeah oh no don't you
she can't pee till lunch we can't take
that break exactly
although she's much happier now in pants
I mean I'm actually no I'd much rather
wear if I could skirt that seems like
knotting not in Vancouver no it's so
it's so funny cuz like I'm an old school
comic book dude but it constantly messes
with my head that all of us nerds who
are into comics like are constantly
fighting for trunks and capes we realize
do you realize that aesthetic comes from
the 30s when the coolest thing a
ten-year-old boy
could you imagine was a [ __ ] circus
performer that was that was the only
image of flying man that's 30 little
boys in the 30s head and we're still
tied to that yo we're lucky we got rid
of the curly-toed shoes and I bet when
they did there was somebody mad about
that take Superman's trunks off that's
not my Superman it's like why the [ __ ]
he ran his underwear on the outside
why and Katyn as we saw from The
Incredibles capes don't make no damn
sense no no kids but no I had a blast
everybody was so wonderful so sweet and
it's a great set to be on and you know
and I got to work with my old friend
Carl Laemmle I saw that picture three
generations just look at all of these
Manhunters this is amazing although
there actually was a scene where we had
a reconciliation because you know the
story line was the Jean Jones and his
father took their you know special
brother mmm
because my character Malik is the only
Martian who cannot read minds and that
made him mad but he had this power where
he could control people instead huh and
so like the idea was like he was out on
the playground it was like all right
we're playing hide and seek Martian
hide-and-seek so everybody I can't find
anybody well I'm just gonna make
everybody hurt all the other kids just a
drop like oh this kid you know
so they stuff in the cave and then he
joins the white Martians like you do
that feels like like the Dave Chappelle
sketch I was gonna do it off the Red
Nosed Reindeer oh sure so taped the
black line white supremacist right what
is Martian name you know all the
Martians are black women is this the
black version of fat man beyond it
absolutely is making [ __ ] blacker as we
go all right so I think I've talked
about the [ __ ] that I'm up to you've
talked about this you up to yeah let's
get into the news let's do some news
dude this is a part of the show where
on the internet and copy and paste
things from other more reputable sources
and read them to you as if you could not
do that I was gonna try to memorize that
so I could do it so I could I do it like
keV yeah the part of the show where mark
so the the thing that I was most
captivated by in the news this week is
how to pronounce camel ah yes oh good 20
is too many that's a lot and she getting
ready for 2024
I mean she's getting ready to be
Attorney General's we're saying but it
seems as if DC is there a bit of a run
recently like the Joker made a billion
dollars
she Sam did very very well Aquaman was a
huge hit Wonder Woman - coming up well
see it's because DC finally figured out
that comic book movie is not a thing
right for years they were just making
let's make a comic book movie it's like
that's not a thing that's like saying
let's make a novel movie what kind of
novel what I mean there are different
kinds oh [ __ ] I gotta fire some of my
executives but the thing they seem to
not have a handle on is Superman yeah
people who write books for living we're
like how do you not get Superman we've
had 80 years to understand how Superman
works and now apparently the Hollywood
guys are like well we have to figure out
how to make him relevant to modern
relevant relevant gritty meta what is
man we're gonna call him man super it's
funny because I always used to think
that Captain America was Marvel's
version of Superman like the hardest
character - right right like I'm good
guy
we're the flat right like everything but
they figured out well with Captain
America they'll the hook was I'm old but
I look hot and young with Superman like
well what are you gonna do it
Smallville they said I'm from Kansas
that was the hook right and the the the
master short of the Captain America was
that they did it without irony it was we
are playing straight with this he is the
best person in the world right and we're
just doing that and we're playing into
what it means to be a patriot in the
best version of that which is I love my
country I love service I love what it
means to be a soldier and I'm a secret
Nazi and I'm a secret Nazi hail Hydra
and like just don't pretend to like wink
at it just just be it and do that let's
see that Warner Brothers side nobody
would ever buy that it's like well you
can't just do it straight yeah he can't
just be good why why how is a person
just good like well well but also
they're fighting against the recognition
problem which in the sense that even
people who don't read comic books or
watch movies have an opinion about how
Superman should act like Oh watch it
don't watch like a look at a poser like
that's not right like you're a [ __ ]
lacrosse player you don't know but I
think and it's it's true that everybody
has an idea of what that Superman is in
their head but I think there's a way I
remember talking to Greg Rucka about
this years and years ago when the first
Man of Steel trailers came out and and
he was like listen I think this looks
great but I'm questioning the wisdom of
making a superman movie that I can't
take an eight-year-old to write you know
like how is this pg-13 like why should
it be pg-13 and that sense of figuring
out what it is distilling down at its
core what makes the Superman story
special and you know and it's so odd
that DC is like how do you make it
relevant to a modern audience
I don't know it's an immigrant story
about a person who's got to pretend to
kind of be something that he's not
to kind of get lin-manuel Miranda right
it yeah I mean if not for nothing if you
made the [ __ ] cans just a musical
[Laughter]
just Clark
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah it's just don't be afraid like when
when these movies work and Marvel figure
this app from the jump don't be afraid
of being what it is
right don't hide from the chord values
of what that means to be and figuring
out what those are you know like and I
think that into the spider verse did it
incredibly well which is what does it
mean to be spider-man right it doesn't
mean that you look a certain way does it
mean that this is the family you come
from it means that you are willing to do
more than everybody else at the risk of
everything in your life right
you know it's sacrifice that's what all
here's where Oh stories are about and so
what does Superman mean what does if you
distill it all the way down it's hope
right like even that Lyman in Man of
Steel like it might be planet this means
hope but it's just like no that's and
it's hope against all odds it's hope in
the face of hopelessness it's I remember
Mark Waid talking about the tragedy of
Superman is that he can hear everything
right he can hear every cry for help and
choose which person he's gonna save Wow
and the tragedies he can't save
everybody and that's what he lives with
as he goes on and it's that desire to
struggle against the impossible and
always know you're gonna fall short but
never stop doing it like there's always
somebody's heartbeat that he hears stop
and he's got to find a way to sleep
every night and get up in the morning
and do it again and know that I can't
save everybody and so like there's
there's even if you just went to the
[ __ ] comics there's a handful there's
an armful of great graphic novels used
to know do birth right do all-star
Superman doing you know there's a bunch
of them out there you know Superman man
for all seasons and like it's all good
[ __ ] you just got to decide to make
Superman movie right and not make
another movie that has Superman on it
[Laughter]
I'm just saying yeah that's Wow
that's but what you said about the
tragedy of it and the fact that he
doesn't give up because then that would
be the Watchmen version of Superman I
can hear all these cries for help
[ __ ] it I'm gonna go this rink yeah he's
literally just like burrows into the
center of the earth and doesn't come up
that's that's [ __ ] Rorschach it's
it's standing on the parallel they will
all look up at me the [ __ ] and the
politicians and they will ask me for
help and I will say no yes where is
Jackie Earle Haley Superman 3 look at
the arm on that kid yeah I just think
about like the half pennies was the
fractional pennies I get Richard Pryor
scam of like you remember that what no
is that is that yet super we have 3
right
oh where he's like listen if I can steal
the free at least the office space game
right if I can steal these fraction of
these pennies then I'll be rich and
nobody count the fraction and of course
he gets caught because they absolutely
count the fractions of pennies are we
fondly reminiscing about Richard Pryor
Superman well we just did Wow
we [ __ ] got there that's nostalgia
mining we [ __ ] got there I just dug
up dirt but it's dirt from my childhood
shot it up so yeah I I think Warner
Brothers needs to widen their gaze a
little yeah and they're starting to it
seems they're starting to but like
Superman of all the problems that there
are in cinema of making things real
Superman does not feel like it should be
one of them right right you know like
it's [ __ ] Superman especially because
it's been done right a couple of times
you know it's the first Superman movie
Smallville you know like the character
that you know that code has been cracked
but just not in a giant blockbuster you
know 21st century way
and like there's there there are things
- like in Man of Steel I'm not the
biggest fan of that movie but there's
things that it does really well but it's
don't don't hide from the fact that
Superman is what Superman is you know
just steer into that skin that's the
only way you make it around this
particular Bend
so yeah just come on water brother so
you can do this I got faith in you you
rap hope I have hope I have hope
hey did you know they're making more
fugitive things like they're remaking
the fugitive places ya know they just
really did come on really maybe maybe a
video game no I didn't kill my wife
[Laughter]
i Richard Kincaid doctor is it dr.
Richard Kimble Kimble cam dr. Richard
Kimble um steel trap mind albert hughes
of the Hughes brothers Oh is gonna
direct the new fugitive from Warner
Brothers yeah I don't know who is going
to star and set a fugitive movie but
does it matter doesn't matter
and then kwibi are you familiar with the
kwibi service nope
so Jeffrey Katzenberg remember that guy
managed to build this company called
kwibi that is going to specialize in
short form entertainment everything
they're doing is less than 15 minutes
long every episode of everything is this
little bite-sized thing because you know
kids so they've got this entire
programming slate that is just these
little bite-sized thing did he's did he
buy vine and kill it he might but uh so
yeah they're doing a version somebody
betting on the death of culture I mean
somebody is oh there's when you get war
you get profit tears exactly there's
always so kwibi kwibi the name of this
company sure I mean I guess who what
point I bet that I bet that translates
into something really cool in Chinese
yeah
he's going for the money and they're
doing one with Kiefer Sutherland ah yes
as dr. Richard Kimble oh wait so kwibi
is doing a fifteen minute version of yes
look I gotta get away hi I got away hey
I think uh my wife
I don't care credit maybe it's a
one-armed now we're out of time I've
seen but yeah Boyd Holbrook and Kiefer
Sutherland are in the bite-sized version
of fugitive and Warren brothers making
another movie version of fugitive now do
you think that was sort of the thing was
like Keepers nothing looked it's like so
I only have to work like three hours a
day I'm now I'm down done what do you
need cuz like 24 was hard things but if
it was just like like this is the
opposite yeah like 15 I'm gonna do 24
anything anymore no no no no 15 that's
that's a little more than half right
Libby Wow see ya I'm not sure we need
another fugitive I'm not sure that's a
story that the world is asking for man
you know what I miss
dudes on the run some somewhere there's
somebody who's nostalgic about the
fugitive I used to watch that movie with
my dad
it'd be cool and then a cop the chasing
- actually maybe kwibi should just
specialize in we're rebooting plots from
failed sixties television shows things
that were only on for a season see what
I would like is for them to be like the
Paul Lynde show because somebody can
somebody reboot that hell yes yeah like
we're doing Otto man just cuz they
should do Albert Hughes when he makes
his it should be like a musical but it's
contemporary but they're singing all the
words from lame is so it's just
literally like Deus like savoring for
eight three two one you saw some bread
oh [ __ ] hey are you a roland emmerich
fan I like something I like it a lot of
his stuff I I can't say that after
Independence Day he's ever actually made
a good movie well I like yourself with
Dean Devlin yeah I mean Stargate and and
Independence Day are pretty great
Godzilla like wildly off the rails but I
will say this nobody commits to
destroying a planet the way Roland
Emmerich commissioned he's like you know
what 2012 we're just [ __ ] it up
there's no coming back
there's no like we have the cure like
you know everything's covered in water
like that John morrow
we're not like there's no more snow it's
just mostly snow and we survived so
here's a tour of dystopia it really is
like nobody commits to carnage the way
that dude does I'm not gonna make no
German jokes it's in his blood
I didn't say it he just got a movie
Greenland called moon fall and I'm gonna
go out on a limb here okay and guess
it's about the day the moon falls on to
the parent planet earth right let's see
if I can give this the plot is about a
mysterious force that knocks the moon
from its orbit around the earth and
sense it hurtling on a collision course
with life as we know it with mere weeks
before impact and against all odds
against all odds ragtag team launches an
impossible last dish mission into space
leaving behind everyone they love and
risk everything to land on the lunar
surface and save our planet from
annihilation its moon again it's Mona
getting but you know what I bet doesn't
happen they save the earth because it's
rolling Emory because that [ __ ]
does not believe in a happy end
[ __ ] it we'll all live it on the moon
now cuz the moon is the new Earth Moon
Moon and I can't wait for moon fall I I
can I can I can wait for another ragtag
team what does the ragtag team gonna be
made up of like astronauts miners a
couple cartographers absolutely in North
Korean sailors sailors yes we just chart
by the Stars right right yeah no
scientists no scientists this is America
in 2019 we don't believe in intelligence
there's no science there's muscle not
like the rock muscle because we can't
afford the rock but like John Cena must
ha ha that's the muscle we can get from
moon fall which it's fine because he's a
darling man he's done come on yes kids
love him
they really do his he is what like Vin
Diesel almost was when he was doing [ __ ]
like you know I'm yeah look like I'm a
cop who's also in a tutu and I gotta
save these kids and take them to daycare
why did Vin Diesel never wrestle that's
where the real money is and the pain and
the pain and the pain it's like Ben's
like no I like my knees I'm fine yeah
I'm good I'm gonna do a giant I'll do
that
hashtag family do I want to star in
movies we're doing money to voiceovers I
am Groot I'll do both I can't wait I
can't wait to go see that I like the
Alamo Drafthouse right I'm just sit
there like just dead like [ __ ] beer
stacked up yeah you need a lot of beers
for moonfall that is a six-pack movie if
ever there was one
and I am on board all right we got one
last news story okay it is way less
cheery than those other ones are you
familiar with the writer DC Fontana you
know DC Fontana was a writer on the
original Star Trek oh wow
she wrote the pilot for a
next-generation encounter Farpoint with
with Gene Roddenberry she written on god
[ __ ] land a lost and Babylon 5 and
God but she was she's a she Dorothy
Fontana is her name but she was writing
long enough ago that a woman could not
work in that industry and just between
1999 1899 but yeah like the 1960s were
not awfully accommodating to female
writers of any kind Wow
we let alone female writers of genre but
DCU soft-pedal to [ __ ] out of that a
little bit not not coming credibly a
comedy they didn't want women they
didn't they didn't believe women they
didn't want them they didn't hire them
unless they were DC Fontana and you
don't know that is a lovely lady who's
about to like just blow your mind
wouldn't know well this writer she great
looking secretary just dropped off his
script but no she passed away I think
the news broke today she's 80 years old
but she is she's like this grand old
game of genre Wow and little life and
there was this great bill Preity had a
little bit that she came to the very
first taping of Big Bang Theory Roy and
then went to every taping for the
entirety of the first season and then
went once a month for the run of the
show she loved it so much and like he
had this this great sort of just kinship
with this woman is like I'm I like
making [ __ ] up
I love nerds you're making a show about
nerds I'm gonna be here for like until
I'm like 78 years old but see what's
what's beautiful about that is so many
of the writers of that generation who
did John Rowe didn't do it cuz they
loved it they did it for a [ __ ] job
and a job that you couldn't tell people
you had yeah like you in 1969 you go to
parties like I write a space show
everybody turned the [ __ ]
and walked away from you yeah we got no
time for you especially if you were well
if you were a woman they didn't even
leave you there's a great episode of
Deep Space nine called beyond the stars
I want to say it is and it's it's set in
like it's it's Benjamin Sisko
'captain hauk a man Quahog like he he
falls in substitue like a coma to begin
a the episode and the majority of it is
in his mind and the the weird
hallucination he's having is he's a pope
writer working for like what would have
been like amazing fantasy right nice I
got some office amazing stories in the
40s and it's populated by like here is
your Jewish bald guy here is your woman
whose name is like Casey Fontaine like
Benny Russell who couldn't like it he
wrote this story about a black guy who's
running a space station in the future
that they wouldn't publish because at
that point the audience was not ready
for a black commander the audience
wasn't the audience wasn't but it's this
amazing sort of look at that slice of
time where these were the people making
your nerd [ __ ] that we all sort of built
upon and would then go and create things
like Star Trek and and and it's it is
it's a brilliant episode of all my
favorite episodes of ds9 but that idea
that they paid tribute to see Fontana
with this character that was played by
not a visitor like Casey Fontaine I
think right yeah but if you've never
seen deep space 9 you could watch that
episode and not need very much context
for anything right and it every Brooks
directed it and really oh yeah and it's
he's giving it he's doing a thing oh
yeah
yes so r.i.p DC fontana sorry to bring
it down but you know what this is a
woman who overcame your huge obstacles
and lets you leave leave behind a legacy
that touches all of us absolutely so
that that's means a good thing yeah so
cheers DC thank you very much and that
is the end of the news news the news
news news is over the news is now old
the news is now old
done so now we have the QA part of our
evening oh you have a question or do you
want to know what do you want to know if
you can go to the bathroom right we have
two sets of giveaways tonight we have as
always some tickets from our good
friends Brett deacon at 40x and
screening my good friend I everybody's
good actually
he's not only my friend he is my
teammate in what Brett Deacon and I are
on a softball team together called
the Rebel Alliance well played
Brett begin is a lovely man and he has
presented unto us sets of tickets 240 X
if you've never been to a 40 X theater
it is like going outside for people who
don't like to be outside and it's it's
for D X wrap 40 X about 40 X people
think oh is that a shirt size I could
wear that not for this audience and it's
certainly not a bra size down nerd down
but yes so it is it is a theater
technology where you go and like the
seat moves and it tilts and this one can
smoke and wind and like that is so fun
yeah it is various like the Tingler but
like the best version yes I'm not sure I
remember Brett saying that they had Ford
versus Ferrari and 40 X oh no it's all
that [ __ ] racing [ __ ] the seats
moving you smell tires and I mean you
come out in a cockney accent right
exactly
it's like dude you haven't lived until
you've heard a Christian Bale accent all
around you I will just whisper your
[ __ ] ear and we also have thanks to
the good folks at Xbox Xbox game passes
so one month unlimited for your console
and our the best question that gets
asked tonight of a download code for
fallen order Star Wars Jedi for the Xbox
one so big anybody here want that
so uh so yeah so come correct bring it
real surrett ain't no tea on it this is
black man Beyond come correct ain't no
half what you think hello my name is
Dennis so I have a question okay
oh good because otherwise you'd be
wasting all our good time yeah we'll
just and I just like holding microphones
so my question is it's a couple of
questions yeah learn it is a three-part
questions three burglars about nerds all
right shoot all right is this just a
title is this a movement is um is it
gaining momentum does it have any
momentum is is this just a way that we
describe black nerds and where do you
guys think it's going if it's going
anywhere
well mark will give the real answer so
I'll start with the [ __ ] answer all
right it is not a movement it is an
evolution the same way that geek culture
has moved into the mainstream and spread
out you know cuz I was joking before
that when I was a kid you couldn't be
black and a nerd that's not a joke like
as far as you know what we identify as
black like look at you reading them damn
books it's like the old Chris Rock bit
you know who hide you want to hide some
hide in a book you know but that's thing
like nerds read books so but now we've
gotten to a point where nerd culture is
mainstream enough that we can all be a
plus it's also grown and grown over time
so that there are enough of us I mean we
were always there yeah you know but we
weren't visible and we weren't feeling
allowed to identify
you know so as we've moved into a
society where more and more you know
unrepresented unidentified people are
now finding voice and finding
representation this to me is the natural
evolution of that I don't have very much
to add that was particularly well done
and I think it's right it's it's it's
allowing yourself to be every part of
yourself you know like we and everybody
does it everybody finds ways to code
switch depending on who they're with who
they are
like if you're with your D&D friends or
you're with your Star Wars friends
totally you know and it had been more
drastic the further back in time you
went where it was you could only be one
of these four things and never together
never inter lapping never overlapping
that's the word but but the the further
we we come to a certain degree as both
people as a culture as a society the
more we're allowing people to be more
than one thing right and so you can be
the person who likes sports who also
plays D&D who also like reads law
manuals just for fun who also who also
who also and I think that blurred is
just an extension of being able to be
those things all at once you know and
and and the african-american community
in particular is a little bit less
forgiving of being more than one thing
and probably and and I think some of
that comes from legacy of having to not
be who you are
and in order to survive in order to
survive so so the idea that you can be a
nerd and be black and be gay or be
straight and be a jock and be all of
these things at once and out loud is uh
is wonderful and a long time coming and
I don't think it's gonna stop the
outloud part is especially cuz like
there was definitely a southern thing
like everybody got a funny uncle but we
just don't talk
you know same thing with the Nerds like
Oh he'd be over there in a corner
reading his books don't worry about but
now yes speak out speak out you know and
finding because it's a thing that we
have always been to a certain degree you
know like it is it is a large MacArthur
was a nerd
that's blurb that's blurred number
wanted blur number one but I think you
know nerd is is it's about passion and
it's about it's about finding yourself
in a fiction that may or may not be
about you and eventually shifting that
fiction to include you and I think for
as long as there have been people there
have been people who were invested in
fiction like we the thing that separates
us from every other animal is the
ability to retain story like literally
money doesn't work unless we believe in
a shared fiction aha because this money
says that it's worth this much gold I
don't see the gold nobody's bringing me
the gold but I believe it you believe it
we all believe that this lie is kind of
true enough that I'll give you this
piece of paper and you will give me that
donkey and everybody's cool right wait a
min you're saying money is a lie that is
the most American thing I've ever heard
but but it's it's it's story that allows
civilization to exist and we've all been
believing in a shared fiction since the
beginning of civilization and so for us
to begin to allow ourselves to share
fictions that don't make the world go
they just make our hearts well and to
find yourself and those in those
fictions is what makes it all worthwhile
and so as we grow older and as we as a
society mature then it's less a movement
it's it's more an evolution it's more a
gist
we're being huh we're using more of our
brains and soon we will be Superman but
for now we're just blurred
see told you give you a real answer
Thank You Dennis come get your
ill-gotten gains
your well gotten gains thank you who are
we going to oh hey man hey that was the
best Kevin impression amen what's it it
Robert
hey Robert nice to meet you thanks for
coming happy thank you sir
what you got so I'm gonna go back to
watchmen okay it's been really gross you
watch The Watchmen i watch the watch I
was wondering who watch the watch okay
so cool ooh this is good yes I just
wanted to get your guys thoughts on
episode I think it was six when they
basically did the origin story mm-hmm
yeah knowing any of the you know
connection to the old stuff or what have
you just amazing that episode was when
they talked about people wearing masks
and yeah a white person wearing a mask
is a black person wearing a mask
is scary so I just yeah I know they're
always hiding something so I I just
wanted to get some why I was such an
amazing episode I felt like the pacing
on that was great I felt like I don't
know like it's just I couldn't stop
watching that episode it was though that
episode and the first Laurie Blake
episode those were the two that got me
on board that one especially because
reading the comic could it justice was
always sort of sidelined you know I felt
like in the comics that character was
more used than explored like he's the
big one and he's gay and he's having sex
and the first one right exactly
but yeah the fact that they like
reconstituted and made him more central
and also like you know like ya know I'm
putting on my white makeup under my mask
you know that's just brilliant
yeah oilers spoilers I mean I think the
the central question of Watchmen seems
to be Who am I right and like that
question has a different answer
depending on who's asking it and so the
African American version that question
is what is my connection to history
given that I don't know so much of it
and to explore that question through the
eyes of you know William Reeves who is
living nineteen different versions of
the answer to that question like I think
I'm a cop I think I'm a New Yorker
although I'm from Tulsa I think that I'm
that I'm doing the right thing I think
that I'm a hero I'm pretending to be
white I'm like all of these these levels
like a like a seven layer dip of rage
and that's not for kids that get that
part not so much for the kiddos but and
the way the episode uses its like dream
logic right it's like sometimes you walk
in this door that's in the middle of the
street you're in a precinct you walk out
of that door you're in a bedroom you
walk through here and you see the fields
of Tulsa in the background and just that
idea that that the emotional truth of
that episode means more than the
structural narrative of that episode and
it's it's how you reveal parts of
yourself and who you choose to reveal it
to and the things that you can never
review and the ways that you are taken
advantage of for the things that you are
and can't be in public you know it's the
the the tragedy of that is the code of
justice just wants to do the right thing
but at every turn he's taken advantage
of until he finally just takes justice
in his own hands and you know it starts
killing folks really violent really
violently but I think that the the
levels to which this show is revealing
to a mass audience a truth about the
african-american experience that they
have never either seen on screen or
reckoned with in this fashion before is
making it for me this kind of essential
viewing and the fact that the question
of the show is Who am I and the vehicle
for that show is race is fascinating to
me just the costume he
you know it wasn't just that I put this
together to look cool like totally it's
thinking logic yet it's of me it's it's
the the the after-effects of the
lynching is the way he decides that I
now present myself to the world as this
person and nobody puts together then
it's a black dude under that mask I
can't hold it in anymore and he just
puts back yeah yeah well and also again
throw them a little more shade to Alan
Moore he had that idea now more when
think about no more [ __ ] lynchings
but the fact I mean that is some like
[ __ ] you know when wing-chun like
retconning yes it's like it in no way in
violates don't came before it in no way
can sit aside like that guy that you've
seen in the Watchmen books we're not
changing it is still that guy just
here's the secret origin that you never
got before and now you can never unsee
that look at it like the everyone thinks
that person is totally just like it is
and I just I love I love the the duality
of hooded justice like well Reeves
having to put the white face I'm here
and then his granddaughter having to put
the black with the black omelet she's
got to be blacker and he's got to be
whiter and the two of them somehow are
finding this weird generational echo
between them that's twisted and shifted
and different and structurally would you
say that there is some similarity
between that episode and the beyond the
stars episode that you were talking
about again absolutely somebody should
do an anthology series where it's just
always somebody in a coma ya know that I
hadn't thought about that but yeah like
they are very similar in that they're
using the the dream logic of memory and
and and weird interplaying illogic of
memory and slowly seeping out of it and
going back into it to dramatize things
that you could not in the standard and
how time repeat so totally the echoes of
everything what we do here echoes
through
eternity [ __ ] gladiator what which
has nothing to do with what that was
just said I just wanted your thoughts no
it is like I'm still trying to put
together my top ten list for for 2019 I
got a bunch of [ __ ] I still need to
watch but I am for real legit thinking
about like Episode six of Watchmen being
one of the best movies I've seen this
year Wow because it's just phenomenal it
should win all the things Lou Gossett
Lou guys on your Homer yes thank you
alright we got one more question and
then we get to choose who gets a Star
Wars game who gets to play a star war
it's the birthday girl what hey how are
you Karen fantastic
what you want to know a few statements
first one I agree Watchmen is awesome
you guys have the same birthday of
course you're gonna agree even though I
love Star Wars I always go into it
knowing to expect it's the same recycled
orphan ink story over and over again
[Laughter]
so anyways I'm a costume designer for
film and stuff like that work on it so
this is always something I love asking
creators okay and everything so when you
go into writing or creating characters
because when it's my job to think of
costume as a separate character do you
guys think about that and when you go
into describing who your character is
and everything and do you actually
consult people to actually make these
costumes and know if it's actually
feasible for me like I most of stuff
when I'm writing because it's not I have
yet to write on a superhero show where
costume is that kind of you know all
right here's the face he's got four
mouths words right is but it's like when
I'm writing it's more describing a mood
it's like this guy is far better dressed
than anybody else
his neighborhood you know and that that
is for him a costume that he's wearing
to conceal to him that he used to be
like it's what's the service of the of
the attire but dramatically what is it
trying to say and then realizing full
well that there are people who do this
for a living who are like way better at
figuring out what that emotional thing
reads as best on skype right um so for
me to say now he's just wearing a Savile
Row suit that's incredibly well cut it's
like whatever but it's like no he's
wearing his father's suit and like
there's patches on the elbows that he's
that he's tried to knit up but hasn't
done very well but still it's as clean
as the suit has ever been you know like
that sort of thing that that tells you
who that guy is
and then then hopefully making this
stuff is always a collaboration as
always there's a team full of horses
trying to pull this thing over the
finish line so then like hey what do you
think it should be like oh that's cool
what are five ways you think this could
be let's all pick the right one I've
read plenty of scripts from like really
yeah I feel like a lot of times if
you're in a script getting too specific
about costumes then you're going off the
rails you know that's that's like
describing the lighting you can you can
say it is misty but you know it's like
we've got a klieg up you know no no no
no no no no that's not your job right
you know you lay out the groundwork I
mean coming from it as an actor yeah I
ain't got no say in it I just got to
pick from whatever the [ __ ] you bring in
you got it pray that I make it
comfortable right or no actually was I
did an episode of superstore last year
where I played a voice actor signing
autographs
[Laughter]
what was your preparation like for that
and it was really really weird because I
went in for my costume fitting and they
literally had on a hanger my shirt like
a shirt that I own I'm like
[ __ ] like Google and me what
the hell did you go in my closet right
did you did you like put everything back
I guess I'll just wear mine psychic
costume designer Wednesday's on the CW
just don't make me look fat oh you want
just keep this together but yeah it's in
the script it's never unless it's very
specific like he is pretending to be a
Gestapo officer so here's what he needs
to have on a uniform of the Gestapo
but like this shirts too small or
whatever like he's like wearing a rabbit
costume you got to make sure there's a
hole clearly yes always don't laugh too
hard people will know but yeah it's all
about the emotional connection between
that character and how you can help tell
that emotional story through the
Wardrobe at least for me as a writer is
all images in putting in there unless
it's like here's a guy again whose dad
gave him a baseball cap from a team that
doesn't exist anymore and so he always
wears this baseball cap and it's gonna
break his heart once he loses it in act
3 like that becomes part of that story
that specific piece it totally but
otherwise like hey just make them look
cool then don't make them look fat
unless he's super fat and supposed to
look fat in which case like you're not
not making my room door yeah Dom DeLuise
is always gonna look fat so this is lean
into it fat and dead nobody wants skinny
Dom DeLuise no he'll pay money for that
somebody should tell Jonah Hill you know
he was making he was making a move out
of comedy into drama wanted an Oscar
yeah but just saying no dramatic actors
have to gain weight comedic actors have
to lose it it's Oscar rules so does that
answer your question it's always good to
hear from other creators soon well thank
you happy birthday happy birthday keep
do you want you come get your tickets
you wanna do one more we could do one
more oh we have one more look [ __ ] it we
could do we have we have no more Xbox
passes but we have 40 X tickets oh hey
that is the best boa I've ever [ __ ]
seen thank you is it actually alive
let's hope not yeah what's your name n
hi I'm Clark hey Clark
happy to be here there you go
I was came with my buddy to attend the
Witcher release Netflix thing where was
that that was right on Hollywood next
yeah Egyptian theater thank you so I was
a fashionably late as usual
and and I and they said you know dress
up if you want for this or for The
Witcher for The Witcher yeah okay I was
gonna say that is somewhere right there
well anyways it is a genre and brand
nonspecific science fiction don't be
getting people sued up in here I had my
picture taken at the Scientology
Christmas exists oh wow you're doing the
bulletin I was so that's why I'm here
excellent as a fan and someone who
appreciates film and oh this is for you
what would be the best way to get in
touch with you guys you know for like
ideas or something we may want to see or
think that would go well like what would
be the best way to keep in touch with
you guys because I feel like a lot of
times the content is great but there's a
couple things might be missing and maybe
some input or feedback or something
comments section on IMDB okay cuz I
never read it yeah and I'm not big on
social media either it's it's it's
incredibly hard as a person who makes
things occasionally to listen to ideas
from the general public the incredibly
fashion they dress public even and it is
never a personal thing it is never like
I don't like you I don't think you're
talented I like you might have the
greatest IDs in the world it is it is
legally impossible for me to hear them
you don't want to get art buchwald yes
deep cut deep Hollywood a lower cut but
you know like let's say you've got an
idea that's amazing you're like listen
dude I got this thing it's all about
coma lady pregnant [ __ ] awesome
and I'm like you know what it is cool
there's nothing I can do with it I don't
have a production company I don't make
movies like and if I do their movies
that I write or it's TV that I'm hired
to work on or it's a TV show that I made
up but I'm not I'm not a taker and then
producer of things right but hey good
idea man hope you have some good luck
and then 15 years later I come up with
an idea about like a lady who's taking a
nap and he decides to transport a very
tiny alien person inside of her stomach
because it didn't know it was a stomach
it's an alien and you like listen man
that's a little close to my and and so
I'm going to sue you and Netflix
incorporated right and it's like not
that I think you would
not that I think I'm pretty sure he
would I don't know he seems a lovely guy
but it's like nobody who does this
professionally unless they're literally
in the business of fielding pitches from
folks can listen to that because it just
opens yourself up to legal action and
damages and loss all of that nonsense
that nobody really wants to have a part
of and like and so it's and I've had to
say this online I've had to say this
like I appreciate that you've got ideas
and I love the fact that some people
want to share them with me I can't hear
them
like I just can't like don't even send
them don't tweet them at me don't
whatever like it's it's it's better for
all parties concerned if we all remain
ignorant of each other beyond hey man
that was pretty cool so hey man thanks
for watching like so I would like in a
perfect world we could just go grab
coffee you could tell me about your
crazy [ __ ] and I'd be like dude that's
[ __ ] crazy awesome you should make
that Saturday we are not inside perfect
world you know well and from from my
standpoint as an actor nobody it will do
nothing for you actors don't create we
interpret so I can give me an idea and I
can read it to someone else
here's Clark's idea it's amazing but you
talk about ideas are just criticism like
if I want to tell you how your [ __ ]
sucked last night where can I go do that
oh that is so sweet up on the internet I
don't think so I watched an episode that
you wrote and I have feelings about it
cool Twitter Instagram like it's all
there let me know and I do read most of
it because I'm a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
learn that lesson don't ever read the
comments because I still kind of
occasionally want to read the comments I
know but here's the thing most of them
are pretty good you know but you know
what's funny when we were about to do
the pee-wee's show that was my first
time performing on Broadway a guy asked
me so when you're on a show opens do you
read the reviews and I'm like is it
don't never read the reviews because the
bad ones are bad and the good ones are
never good enough that's fair
my problem is is that I used to be a
critic yeah like I'm acutely aware of
the desire to see how the audience feels
about something you know see how how
it's hitting people and some of it's
anecdotal something you run into it's
they've not really dug that cool thanks
but like I'm still like hey man so what
would have that go you still feel like
you're on the other side a little bit
well stranger in a strange land
information on that border what does
that answer your question yes so us as
fans constructive criticism let's not be
so hard on everybody you know yeah like
could what I try to do when I'm when I'm
like watching TV sure watching movie or
whatever it's never personal and it's
always about finding a lesson in the
work and sometimes that lesson is a good
one sometimes it's a do or do not do but
it's always in an effort to digest and
dissect how a thing works it doesn't
work so that I can be a better writer so
that we can all have a little bit more
information about just how they do this
thing because you know nothing is as
instructive as a bad movie you know um
for both craft and ego reasons like
that's shitty I made the [ __ ] a my
[ __ ] can it get made - it's no better
it's no worse interesting Thanks
2012 I actually had to think about wait
wait you are we in again
well lastly lastly that's last thing I'm
gonna say them not this Mike but uh you
know appreciate you guys and everything
you do you touch your fans in many ways
you may not even see you here comes the
law stop it guys no you touch your fans
like in ways you may not even know so
very much appreciative thank you
appreciate thank you thank you Oh
come have some fancy tickets Clark here
you go thank you all right we got one
more he's standing right there why don't
you just touch his arm sorry it took me
a long time to get here there's no
worries I came all the way from Chicago
it took me a while also that explains
why you're late yeah twice LA traffic I
like white people time we understand
yeah thank you
well what's your name my name is Natalie
and I go thank you for coming Natalie my
question is for you guys while we see
the sci-fi community the comic community
moving forward with various movies that
are accentuating black actors and
accentuating all ethnicities because
Ryan my question is is when do we start
getting and how do we start getting
creators on the ground floor to start
making something completely different
something completely outside the realm
about culture about a style about
everything else that is all about the
ethnic communities whether it's Native
American black Kenyan any other
Pakistani Indian
Chinese how do we get to that point for
the acceptance I feel like it's it's
happening in fits and starts some of
those fits are huge and fast and lovely
and wonderful like you get a thing like
black panther comes out and it makes two
billion dollars you're gonna get more
things like black panther cuz everybody
wants money because hollywood has
motivated entirely by cash and if you
can show them that cash pays that the
diversity pays that you know when when
when you have a movie like fast and
furious 5 I want to say a whole lot of
white people
minotaurs ask the Furious Alive became
like oh it's the United Colors of
Benetton stealing cars and it's like oh
and you know what it made nine hundred
million dollars across the world right
and it seems as if an audience will show
up for this in a way that they will not
show up for like three white boobs just
doing [ __ ] exactly you know unless it's
The Hangover
bang you know or like they will always
show up reliably for what they've always
gotten but the outside success is based
entirely on the makeup of the people
either behind the camera or in front of
the camera with comparative budgets or
what will change that narrative so it's
when you get directors like Cary
Fukunaga or directors like Ava Duvernay
or directors like Ryan Coogler you know
making movies that are coming from a
different perspective that seems to
harmonize with the global community
because they could give a [ __ ] how much
money a movie makes me the u.s. they
really care how much makes in China and
how much makes them in Japan and how
much it makes in Africa how much you
make South America like the global
audience is five times bigger than the
domestic audience so what will they show
up for it turns out lots of different
things but even in the Star Wars
franchise let me utilize that for the
first one two and three that the
original right a whole lot of white
people in a few characters and Samuel
Jackson just saying
but wave away which which ones are you
talking about one QE Chris I'm not
talking about four-five effects got one
two and three right I mean those were
still and they made a lot of money
worldwide but it was my biggest Star
Wars was always kind of going to make a
lot of money worldwide and they were
made by a 70 year old white dude who's
been making like four movies over the
last 90 years who never leaves his house
and so like yeah I'm gonna put a black
dude it's gonna be Sam [ __ ] Jackson
the one black dude I know that and the
purple oh for sure Jackson but it's it's
it's finding filmmakers whose eyes are
open to the rest of the world from both
a narrative perspective and an audience
perspective so is your suggestion for
everybody else to not see any other
films that are not representative no I
mean I think it's it's I don't think
it's fair I'm being completely honest I
don't think it's fair and I don't think
it's right and I think that there needs
to be inclusion we're talking about a
galaxy not just a planet not just the
universe we're talking about an entire
galaxy yeah I mean it's how do we do it
well know cuz I mean what you're talking
about is you're saying how do we get the
process that is in process faster faster
you can't how do you make the Sun go
around or earth faster it doesn't
because it doesn't go around the earth
this is thought not sanitarium well you
got to remember cuz you say about money
drives everything and that's true but
technology is also driving everything
for instance you see much greater
diversity in representation and ideas in
television than in films yeah why
because the audiences have broken down
when we were kids there were three
channels and each one of them had 50
million people watching everything like
30 million people showed up for every
episode of mash you know now you have
nine thousand channels and 17 people
watching them each well they can be
because now we're no longer aiming to
get a majority of fifty million people
at once because that's that was the
mentality before also people are much
more aware of concepts like diversity
and representation than they were so
there's money but there's also
consciousness but also the money part
has broken down to like oh I don't have
to appeal to the majority of the people
in the United States which in 1977 were
white people so and there was there was
literally I mean cuz I started this
business in the late 80s and it was the
mentality was just beginning to change
I remember when Erica saw was on e on a
on ER as a surgeon yeah not an orderly
he was a surgeon that was groundbreaking
like everybody under 40 is like what
really no sir see there was a time where
I was auditioning for gang member parts
and getting them yeah well he's darker
than a paper bag that's very threatening
to me
you're hired how can we help Nora how
can we help to progress
everybody collect my theory yeah
diversity is not about statistical
representation solely it is about
excellence the reason we want more
points of view more faces is because it
increases the likelihood that [ __ ] will
be good changing right if you get is
just the same eight white beats telling
the same story over and over again well
let's do Mannix let's do Jake in the fat
man let's do Petrocelli
he was the same [ __ ] we're all you know
abiding and and nobody cared but now you
know we we don't have to aim for that
you know lowest common denominator
necessarily we can aim for what everyone
and
can try to make it as good as possible
so I think if audiences go towards the
things that are the best they will you
will find that you'll you're heading for
a diverse group of ideas because like
I'm not watching the same thing over and
over again I love this because it is new
it is unique it is O story it is a world
as a point of view I've never seen
before I love that that to me is the key
excellent answer thank you so much yeah
like Phil said but I'll also say there's
there's a weirdness of like when you
look at the the top 10 shows in 1977
it's good times it's what's happening
it's it's like Sanford and Son
it's TV was blacker in 1977 than it is
now and all those shows were getting 30
million people watching them you know
The Jeffersons was massive in a way
right and and the fracturing of the
audience or the maturing of the audience
has both helped and hindered it to a
certain degree where when you only have
three networks and those networks are
like you know what black people bought
TVs let's put on a show and you can't
change the channel
everybody's watching it right and now
that there's 500 channels and 4,000
scripted shows nobody's watching
anything good bad or indifferent
so like Watchmen no matter what you feel
about it it's only getting like eight
nine hundred thousand people a week well
half the people is room I'm sure don't
have HBO right and can't watch it
so they pirate it don't do that don't do
that people gotta get paid but I think
it's when you find something that you
feel like you might respond to
supporting like go see it like last year
was last year this year I can't [ __ ]
remember anymore there's a movie that
came out and I talked about on the
podcast called fast color and it was
directed a female director Julia Hart
made this lovely story about three
generations of black women each of which
have superpowers it's the best like
x-men movie that you've never seen
because nobody saw it it open
the week before and well nobody saw Dark
Phoenix either true but at least you
knew it was kind of coming right you
know fast it all it was in like 23
theaters around the country the weekend
before endgame opened and then vanished
let's see that's that's the problem with
feature films is that it is becoming is
becoming it's becoming television in the
70s right there's three channels in
China and to your point about time and
the time that things take content moves
at different speeds depending on the
medium films move the slowest of
anything it takes 10 years to make a
movie give or take especially at that
level right from script to casting to
production to post whatever videogames
are pretty slow too
video games are super slow as well
television is faster because it has to
be faster there's more TV it's got to
come out periodically it's you know once
every week and that gotta have a new
season next year so change happens
faster in TV that it doesn't film
commercials happen almost immediately
like it takes three weeks from idea to
air for a commercial and that's why the
commercials are almost always the
tipping point of representation where
there's like hey that's an interracial
family hey is that Cheerios girl yeah
the point that a lot of the commercials
and a lot of things that reach purple
people instantaneously that they want to
see we don't get that oh he wants you to
move into the camp he wants you to stay
in there it's bright and I can't see I'm
blind yeah I mean it's it's less it's
less the things that they're selling in
the commercials but it's how they're
selling and who they're selling them to
and you can see that kind of change have
been faster their music also happens
very quickly because it's I could write
a song I do a [ __ ] lyrics video and
it's up on YouTube tomorrow you know and
but video games take 8 9 10 years and so
it's so rare to find like oh hey horizon
zero dawn we got a game with a female
protagonist how long has this been in
production how's the team but I think
the problem is video games is less about
time then mind right but it's like the
same people are hiring for these games
and it's a very
selective group of people who know how
to do that they're rarely inviting new
people in because they're working on the
same [ __ ] game for 10 years you know
there was this there's amazing thread
that went around about Jim Henson and
and why it's so difficult to find female
puppeteers and it was when Jim Henson
star the Henson workshop he was the lead
puppeteer and he's like he made all
these Big Damn puppets and only his long
arms could reach he look he's six three
right and so he built the sets for him
so that had to be comfortable so like
he's got to stick his hand up a bunch of
puppet asses and he doesn't want to be
like cramping when he's doing it so
because they built the sets that high
most of the puppeteers that they had to
hire were also that tall and so most of
them by just sheer physical numbers were
dudes because they're not a ton of 6-3
women who also wanted to be puppeteers
and now Jim Henson passed away like 20
years ago but they just still build the
sense that hi because that's just how
they always did it they never
interrogated it it's that like the the
unconfirmed bias of we built the thing
this way we always put them in this way
it makes it hard for us to hire women
because women aren't this tall and just
they always complain but what point does
we've always done this way this is what
we've always done become a hindrance if
you ask it totally collectively you know
it's it it is always it's a hindrance
long before anybody recognizes that it's
a hindrance because it's amazing what
human beings can get used to you know I
mean it's it's and it just took somebody
saying why are there not more female
puppeteers to like oh here's why now we
can build these sets smaller because we
know we need to you know it's like
China's reckoning with that one child
policy like it real hard right now
there's like hey you know we did you
don't have any women because we
encourage people to like not have girl
children so now there's a bunch of
[ __ ] bachelor dudes trying to score
like we're having problems sustaining a
population because of our own
shortsightedness I just feel that
anytime that there is a situation
whether it's race sex high
wait anything else where we decide as a
society that says well this is the way
that we've always done it that will
continue well but also not every period
not everything is always the way it's
been done it's the way people remember
it being done like all this stuff other
stuff about no bathrooms and you know
the gender in the bathrooms when public
restrooms were first introduced they
were not gendered but then we made them
desert everybody shits van and women
[ __ ] you're on the street everybody
needs to shave there's a kids book about
that as there is then when you keep it
how it's the status quo and what
everybody says
everybody else this is how it should be
that's when we start failing as a
society right that's all I mean ever
yeah I mean like that because people
people are scared of change even change
towards something better and that's
that's that that is it that is the human
condition yeah and so we just have to
examine those things we don't examine a
lot that's why you stay with that hope
that horrible boyfriend and nobody likes
why you think she left
why do you think I'm leaving tomorrow
from my way
ha ha ha got to prove to you guys well
that you Thank You Natalie
I think did you sign the things you know
sorry those are for you ok I had nothing
to do with any of those we have to we
need to pick who gets who gets the the
fallen order big is Dennis is Dennis
still here Dan is
then it says come get your video game
Dennis I hope you got an Xbox or or have
friends Jonas that is the end of QA
which means sadly I think we've come to
the end of our show I know I'm sorry
no more free drinks that's right
can somebody please find marks credit
card yes like what's left of it like
it's smouldering who who bought a Datsun
did you hear that blender going all
through the show there they were
drinking fancy drinks on your bill
I saw umbrellas and [ __ ] flying Oh
goddammit but listen I just want to
thank Phil Lamarr for coming out and
playing with me tonight it's a little
bit late it's a little bit wet but
[ __ ] Phil comes to play so thank you
brother I come to fight you come to the
phone but that is black man beyond for
this week my name is Mark Barnard and
that is Phil Lamarr come back next week
same time same fat check same black
times and glass ha ha ha smart guess
that comes ask Evan Smith good night
everybody
[Applause]
you